what we have here is a free response
question that you might see on an ap
microeconomics type exam that deals with
game theory and it tells us
bread basket and quick lunch are the
only two sandwich shops serving a small
town so we're in an oligopoly situation
where we only have a few firms
each shop can choose to set a high price
or a low price for sandwiches
the payoff matrix below shows the daily
profits for each combination of prices
that the two shops could choose
the first entry shows bread baskets
profits and the second entry shows quick
lunches profits assuming that both shops
know the information shown in the matrix
answer the following
so just to make sure i understand what's
going on here this is saying that for
example if bread bread basket can either
choose to charge high prices or low
prices quick lunch can either choose to
charge high prices or low prices if the
if bread basket chooses high prices
prices and quick lunch also chooses high
prices then what this tells us is the
first one is bread baskets profit per
day would be 105 dollars while quick
lunches profit per day would be 110 and
then this is a situation where bread
basket is low and quick lunch is high
price and then bread basket would make
120 and quick lunch would make 80. and
then when quick lunch has low prices we
can see what are the profit of either
when bread basket charges high prices or
bread basket charges low so with that
out of the way let's try to answer these
questions
does each shop have a dominant strategy
to set a high price a dominant strategy
to set a low price or does it have no
dominant strategy so pause the video and
try to figure that out and just as a bit
of a hint or reminder a dominant
strategy is a strategy of regardless of
what the other player does you would
still be better off to make that choice
so a dominant strategy of setting a high
price would be regardless of whether the
other player decides to set a high or
low price a high price would always make
sense for you so pause the video and try
to see if you can answer that
all right now let's see what bread
baskets situation is here
so if we think bread basket of course
can either choose to go high or low
now if quick lunch goes high what should
bread basket do
well then we are in this column over
here and these two numbers are for bread
basket and so quick lunch goes high then
bread basket could go high in charge 105
or it could go low and charge 120. so if
quick lunch goes high bread basket
should go low so let me write this quick
lunch
quick lunch
if it chooses to go high
then bread basket should go low now what
happens if quick lunch chooses to go low
well if quick lunch chooses to go low
the two options for bread basket are
either 40 dollars a profit per day if
they have a high price because a lot of
their business would go to quick lunch
in that situation or they could go low
price and make 75 dollars per day so
even if quick lunch goes low it still
makes sense for bread basket to go low
so bread basket
goes low so we see that bread basket no
matter what quick lunch does it makes
sense for bread basket to go low so
bread basket has a dominant strategy to
set a low price so dominant
dominant
strategy
to set
let me write that a little bit clearer
set low
price all right now quick lunch
so we could do the same type of analysis
based on what bread basket might choose
to do
so
if we see okay if bread basket goes high
what should quick lunch do
well let's see if then quick lunch
should so if bread basket goes high
quick lunch should it go high or low so
it would have an option of
or it would have an option of 130 so if
bread basket goes high quick lunch is
better off going low so let me write
that down quick lunch should go low and
if bread basket goes low what should
quick lunch do
so if bread basket goes low quick lunch
can either make 80 if it goes high or 70
if it goes low so in this situation if
bread basket goes low it makes sense
actually for quick lunch to go high and
make the 80. so quick lunch would go
high
so quick lunch has no dominant strategy
it doesn't make sense for them to always
go lower always go high regardless of
what bread basket is doing depending on
bread basket it might make sense for
them to go low if bread basket goes high
or high if bread basket goes low so no
dominant
strategy
if the two shops do not cooperate on pri
on setting prices what will be the
profit for each shop
well actually just pause the video see
if you can answer that before we work
through it
well we already know that bread basket
has a dominant strategy to set a low
price so bread basket is going to go low
regardless
so that we're going to end up in this
row right over here and if we are in
that situation where bread basket goes
low regardless we know that it makes
sense for quick lunch to go high because
they can either make 80 or 70 well
they're going to go high and so we're
going to end up in this column right
over here
so if the two shops do not cooperate on
setting prices the profit of each shop
would be bread basket would be making
120 a day and quick lunch would be
making
80 a day and this is a nash equilibrium
because on its own no firm can change
its decision to optimize its prices more
because if you are in this if you are in
this cell right over here quick lunch
can't change bread baskets decision so
quick lunch could say i'm either going
to make 80 or i'm going to make 70. so
it wouldn't make any sense for them to
switch away and then breadbasket they
can't make the decision for quick lunch
they can say hey we're either going to
make 120 or we're going to make 105. and
so since we can't change what quick
lunch is doing well of course we're
going to choose to make 120. so people
will stay in this bottom left cell we're
in nash equilibrium
all right so the next part they ask us
or they tell us
the town government is concerned that
food prices are too high it decides to
give a daily subsidy of twenty dollars
to any shop that chooses to set a low
price for its food items
redraw the payoff matrix under the
government subsidy system so like always
pause this video and go through that
exercise it'll be interesting
all right now let's do this together so
we have bread basket i'll try to write
bread actually let me draw my little
matrix first
so
it's a two by two
almost done with my
matrix
and one more that wasn't near the middle
there you go right around there
still maybe there
and then we have that there
and then we have high
low high
low
and then you have quick
lunch if i were actually doing this on
the test maybe i would write this a
little bit lower so it's a little bit
neater and then this is bread
basket
and let's see the the it's giving a
daily subsidy of 20 so we could just do
that that adds to the profit of a firm
that is selling at low prices so if
they're both at high prices that's not
they're not going to be able to get that
subsidy from the government so we're
still going to be at 105
and 110
for bread basket and quick lunch
respectively
now if bread basket stays high in this
situation well then they're still only
going to make forty dollars but in this
situation right over here quick lunch is
going to get a 20 subsidy because they
are choosing to go low so they're going
to make 130 plus 20. so i'll write that
in a different color so i would put that
in
and i'll i'll put this in red so 130
plus 20 they're going to make 150
because they're choosing to go low price
here that's what what qualifies you for
the subsidy and in this situation if
bread basket goes low price they're
going to make
120 what they would have made in that
situation plus 20 so this is going to be
but this is a situation where quick
lunch is charging a high price so
they're not going to get the subsidy so
they're still going to make 80
and then this sells both of them
charging a low price so they're both
going to get 20 more than what you see
right over here so bread basket would
make ninety five dollars
ninety five dollars and quick lunch is
going to make
ninety dollars in this situation
and let's see they ask us more questions
they say
using your redrawn payoff matrix answer
each of the following
would quick lunch choose to set a high
price or low price explain using
specific values from your redrawn matrix
so pause the video and see if you can
answer that
all right so we're going to look at
quick lunch now and we could do the same
type of analysis to see if they have a
dominant strategy we could say okay if
bread basket
goes high
what is quick lunch going to do
so if bread basket goes high now in this
situation quick lunch will either oh hi
and make 110 or could go low and make
150 so quick lunch is going to go low in
this situation and if bread basket goes
low
quick lunch can make 80 if it goes high
or can make 90 if it goes low so once
again quick lunch
is going to go low
so
quick lunch
quick
lunch
now
has
dominant
strategy
for low price
for low
price
and i could try to explain this out if
if bread basket goes high i'll write it
out here normally you have a little book
to write this in but
if
bread i'll abbreviate bread basket goes
high
quick
lunch
what is rational to
make 150 instead of 110
would
want
to
make
150.
versus 110
by
going
low
if
bread basket
goes
low
goes low
quick lunch
makes
ninety dollars
versus
versus eighty dollars
by
going
low
all right would the profits for bread
basket increase decrease or stay the
same explain with a comparison to your
answer in part b1 use specific values
so before
subsidy
actually pause this video and try to do
this as well
before subsidy and i'll do it together
before subsidy
quick lunch or i should say bread basket
bread basket
was
making
and we have it up here
so if the two shops do not cooperate on
setting prices what will be the profit
of each shop we saw bread basket would
make 120 dollars because that was that
nash equilibrium state
after subsidy
after
subsidy
so let's look at it we still have bread
basket still has a
dominant strategy to go low because if
quick lunch goes high bread basket is
would want to make the 140 instead of
105 and if quick lunch goes low bread
basket would want to make 95 instead of
40. but now they both have a dominant
strategy for going low so we're going to
end up in this bottom right
with this bottom right cell
after subsidy both
have dominant
dominant strategy
to
go low
resulting
in 95
profit
for
bread basket
and so 95
is less than 120
so bread baskets
profit
goes or i should say decreases decreases
and we are done